the movie is based on a true story and
it revolves around a brave Freedom
individual named Eric Liddell at the
start a narration explains how Eric had
won a gold medal in the 400 meter race
in the 1924 Olympics however despite
getting tons of offers from various
American brands to continue his Sports
career Eric had declined all of them it
turns out that he was born in China and
so right after the Olympics Eric
returned back to his birthplace to serve
as a missionary a person who promotes
Christianity in a foreign country there
he married the love of his life nurse
Florence McKenzie Eric then spent most
of his years in China teaching chemistry
English and even Athletics in the
anglo-chinese college despite being
Scottish by descent he cared a lot for
the Chinese people as he regularly
provided the poor communities with needs
and services however during that time
the ongoing war with the Japanese slowly
spread across the country which brought
a lot of misery to the Chinese one day
Eric goes to school where he teaches and
notices one of his students is late to
class he spots the absentee from outside
the window running towards the school
with a basket full of pears all of a
sudden several warplanes emerge out of
the sky and drop a bomb near the school
brutally killing the child outside
devastating Eric life in China has now
become so dangerous because of the
Japanese aggression that the British
government advises its Nationals to
leave the country a pregnant Florence
and their two daughters immediately
decide to leave for Canada But Eric
stays back in China he instead accepts a
position at a rural Mission Station in
xiaoxiang which serves the poor before
leaving Florence asks Eric's assistant
and good friend shu to take good care of
her husband he reassures her that he
will keep them safe at all costs and
with this Florence and the children
board their ship and depart a while
later Eric and shoe drive back home only
to find that the Japanese Imperial Army
has looted and taken over his residence
however Eric is not saddened by the
sight he instead begins to pray for
strength and guidance with his home now
uninhabitable Eric is left with no
choice but to seek Refuge elsewhere he
turns to the school where he teaches
which has been converted into a shelter
for refugees fleeing the war-torn areas
here Eric finds himself bonding with the
displaced families sharing in their
struggles and offering whatever support
he can every morning Eric leads the
refugees on a run hoping to uplift their
spirits and provide a sense of normalcy
in their lives despite the hardship and
uncertainty that surrounds them Eric's
unwavering faith and kind heart Bring
hope and Solace to those around him
during one of his morning runs Erica
comes across a small child named Xiao
wandering alone on the streets moved by
the child's plight Eric brings him back
to the school and provides him with a
safe place to live as time passes he
grows close to Xiao and becomes like a
father figure to him he teaches him to
read and write and provides him with a
sense of stability and belonging in a
world that has been turned upside down
by War one day while Eric is checking
the mail he discovers a letter from
Florence his beloved wife who has been
in Canada with their daughters through
it he learns that they have welcomed a
new addition to their family a baby girl
the news fills Eric with a sense of joy
and gratitude knowing that despite the
distance between them his family is safe
and thriving I guess his wife is even
asexually reproducing right right that
same evening Eric gathers with the
refugees in the school to celebrate the
news of his daughter's birth the
atmosphere is one of joy and hope as
they all come together to share in his
happiness as the evening wears on Eric
and Shu begin to talk about their
families and loved ones Eric reveals
that his brother is stationed at a
hospital in the nearby city of shashwang
and that the hospital is in dire need of
medical supplies the missionaries there
have exhausted their resources and the
situation is growing more desperate by
the Day determined to help his brother
and the patience in need Eric offers to
donate his last possession a treasured
watch that has been in his family for
Generations so after several days of
planning and preparation Eric Shu and a
few other volunteers discreetly
purchased the much-needed medical
supplies from a nearby hospital because
as the Japanese have prohibited such
transactions they carry out their
operation at night to avoid detection
the next day the team sets out in a
truck loaded with the supplies
determined to reach the hospital in
shashwang along the way they encounter a
border control checkpoint where Japanese
soldiers are strictly enforcing
restrictions on travel as they approach
the checkpoint Eric and his team are
stopped by the guards and asked to
explain their presence Eric shows them
an old newspaper featuring his
photograph on the front page
highlighting the victory in the 400
meter race at the Olympics the guards
are intrigued and ask Eric what he's
doing in China and when they learn that
he is a school teacher they let him pass
sometime later they eventually reach the
hospital and hand out all the supplies
to the needy in the next scene we are
shown that the Japanese have initiated
war with the US after their attack on
Pearl Harbor consequently while Eric is
officiating a marriage the Japanese
Imperial Army stormed the church and
sabotaged the wedding Eric along with
all the wedding attendees and many other
people are taken to the vice sign
internment prison camp where they are
held against their will the leader of
the Japanese Imperials explains that
they will be organized into groups where
the people who have families will be
kept together while all the others will
be separated one night the guards wake
Eric up and take him to the commander of
the Imperial Army turns out he wants to
race Eric and beat him as he had heard
of his Olympic achievements so Eric is
given special care and is provided with
better food than the other prisoners
however instead of keeping the food to
himself he shares it with his fellow
prisoners even though it's a risky move
meanwhile Shu and the child Xiao search
for the missing Eric and finally find
the camp where he is being capped to
help him the two manage to get cleaning
jobs inside the prison camp one day
while Eric is teaching the kids
chemistry outside he spots them doing
labor much to his surprise shoe then
hides a bag full of goods for Eric under
a tower which he picks up later that
night by sneaking outside he takes the
bag inside and opens it in front of his
fellow prisoners and they are amazed to
see fresh fruits and vegetables along
with many other items which are
restricted inside the camp just think of
about this scene next time you are
turning down your broccoli at dinner in
the next scene the day of Eric's race
with the commander finally arrives and
everyone cheers him on to win however it
is evident that Eric is very weak and
malnourished as he hasn't eaten any of
the special foods which were given to
him the race commences and Eric
initially takes the lead but due to his
weak body he falls over while running
and loses the race all of a sudden one
of Eric's friends named David speaks up
for him yelling that he is starving and
hasn't had anything to eat the Commander
in the other guards are confused upon
hearing this and question Eric whether
or not he had eaten the food that they
had given him after finding out the
truth the commander is furious and so
Eric along with David are beaten up and
taken to his solitary confinement hole
where they are kept in for days on end
as punishments one night shoe sneaks
inside the camp and approaches Eric
offering him food and water but seeing a
weak and desperate David starving beside
him in another hole he offers his food
to him as well she then begs Eric to let
him help him escape the camp as the
Japanese might have planned on killing
him however Eric refuses to leave his
people behind and decides to stay
stating that they need and depend upon
him a few days later the two prisoners
are eventually released from the
confinement cell and taken back to their
rooms where they are cheered on by the
others however Eric's relief is
short-lived as he is assigned to perform
intense manual labor within the prison
compound one day he discreetly meets and
talks to Shield the latter reveals that
because of Japan's poor results from the
ongoing War the food supply to the
prison camp has been cut off he then
tells Eric that he's made a deal with
some of his connections inside the
prison the deal makes the guards turn
off the electric fence twice every month
which will allow the little kid's Xiao
to be able to sneak inside the prison
camp to provide food supplies to some of
the dubious guards as well as Eric and
the prisoners that very night Xiao is
able to sneak into the camp undetected
delivering bags filled with much needed
food items to the starving prisoners
however the next day trouble Brews as
some guards catch David's smoking
outside his room and punish him severe
desperate and fearing for his life he
turns to shoe for help pleading with him
to assist in his escape from the camp
despite the high stakes Shu and Xiao
hatch a daring plan to sneak David out
in a container meant for human waste
luckily the plan turns out to be a
success and David escapes without any
trouble while the troops inside the camp
are Furious about his disappearance he
escaped that's that's no he escaped
in the Commander's frustration
reaches a boiling point as he questions
every single inmate about David's Escape
but none of them provide any useful
information desperate he takes one of
the prisoners named Hugh and throws him
into solitary confinement hoping that
the threat of punishment will force
someone to speak up as tensions in the
camp continue to rise Eric's Health
takes a turn for the worse it begins to
experience frequent nosebleeds a sign
that his physical condition is
deteriorating rapidly after a long and
grueling confinement Hugh is finally
released but his condition is dire he
urgently needs medical attention for
pneumonia and the other prisoners are at
a loss for how to help him however Eric
refuses to give up hope when he
discovers that one of the other inmates
is a doctor he works tirelessly with him
to provide the best possible care for
Hugh hoping to save his friend's life
but they soon realize that the medical
supplies they need are not available
within the camp desperate for a solution
Eric hatches a daring plan he approaches
the Commandment major of the Imperial
Army and challenges him to a race with
the condition that if he wins he can
call any person from outside the camp to
bring in the necessary medical supplies
the major initially rejects The Proposal
but later accepts thinking that he will
easily win the race because of Eric's
weak and frail body and gives him until
the end of the week to train so without
delay Eric trains his frail body to its
limit determined to win the race despite
the warnings from the other prisoners
who assume that it will be a death
sentence for him the day of the race
arrives but the other prisoners are
forbidden from leaving their rooms and
watching it unfold hence they pray for
Eric's success and starts singing hoping
that their voices will carry over to him
soon the race begins and everyone holds
their breath in suspense Eric starts off
slowly but gradually picks up speed and
begins to pull ahead of the Commandment
major to everyone's shock he crosses the
Finish Line first despite his exhausted
body as a result of his historic win
Xiao is granted access inside the camp
that night he brings loads of medicine
making all the prisoners ecstatic
however their happiness is short-lived
as one of the commanders enters the
power supply room and orders the guard
to go outside immediately realizing that
the commander will turn the fence on
while Zhao is climbing the guard heads
to the prisoner's room and warns Eric
about it hearing this all the prisoners
frantically rush to the electric fence
and shouted shout to jump off
unfortunately all their efforts are in
vain as the evil Commander manages to
turn the fence back on electrocuting
shell and killing him right in front of
everyone both Eric and Shu are
heartbroken to see Xiao hanging from the
fence while the commander arrives on the
scene and warns everyone that the
Japanese Imperial Army is not to be
messed with a few silent days pass by in
the prison camp and due to the lack of
treatment a sick Hue dies in his bed
Eric musters the strength to inform his
pregnant wife Catherine who Falls to her
knees upon hearing the tragic news the
weight of the loss hangs heavily over
the camp the next day it's revealed that
Eric had been granted access to go home
by Christmas however he talks to the
Commandment major and convinces him to
let Catherine go in his place wanting to
preserve her and her unborn child's life
one day Eric dies of a brain tumor
inside the prison camp he however gets a
proper burial due to the courage and
Valor he has shown all his life all his
friends pay respect to his grave while
Shu also visits the camp and gets
emotional bursting into tears the movie
ends five months after Eric's death
where the prisoners get the relieving
news that Japan has surrendered in the
war granting them freedom from the
prison camp subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching